this is Josh Topolsky and we are at
Apple's Worldwide Developers Conference
in San Francisco three big takeaways
today our first Apple really wants to be
in music in a big way no matter what's
going on in the world so you've got
Spotify and Pandora nipping at its heels
they introduced a new service called
Apple music that aims to take on those
services and maybe some more they're
launching radio stations that are not
that dissimilar from what serious is
offering in satellite radio and they're
also creating a new service called Apple
music connect which lets artists share
photos and new songs with listeners the
company also introduced a lot of new
features for iOS 9 the new version of
its mobile operating system but the most
significant one might be the ability on
the iPad to be able to use two apps
side-by-side making it much more of a
productivity device as opposed to just a
Leanback machining one other thing you
might have noticed today about Apple is
that they're definitely on the attack
they launched a new service called Apple
news which is definitely taking a shot
at Flipboard and they made several
comments about privacy and user data
that was clearly aimed at Google and
Facebook and finally they introduced a
new service called Apple intelligence
which is very much like Google now and
is all about predicting how you're going
to use your device and it aims to make
your apps more integrated with one
another all in all this is definitely a
developer's conference there were a lot
of iterative updates to software and
services but no huge wham bang moments I
think the closest the company got is the
introduction of the new music service
which if it actually taps into itunes
full library of songs could be a fierce
competitor in that space
you